- Gasps!
- There's nothing in the human
world that feels like this.
- Oh they are squishy.
- What am I doing.
- Smash it.
- Squish squish.
- Squeeshy.
- Squish squish bish.
(light playful music)
- I have never heard of Squishies before.
- Maybe they're a new
type of fidget spinner.
- Squishies are these
little foamy creatures
- I've seen other people with
them and I get super jealous
and I really want one, it
look so fun and cool and cute.
I think Squishies are trending
because the world we live in
just keeps on getting
more and more stressful.
- I see where they get the
name from now, oh this is fun.
(upbeat music)
- This feels like a stress
ball but even squishier.
- They're so squishy.
- And they're super soft.
- These are like dog toys for adults.
- I don't actively play with
any toys still as an adult.
- Can I have all of them?
- I really like these way
more than I thought I would.
- Ohh they smell good.
- I feel like if I choose one
then the other squishies are gonna be sad
that I didn't choose them.
- They're all staring at me.
Look.
Do you see this right now
- (gasps) look how (laughs).
- I'm gonna take this with me for a week,
just hang out with it,
play around with it,
and kinda see how it affects me.
- I'm pretty sure I will
get into fights with kids
who will try to grab this from
me and that's not happening.
These are my toys.
- I'm a very stressed person,
so I feel like they'll be
in handy when I'm stressed.
- Am I suppose to like
squeeze it when I'm upset.
(cries)
- I think I'm already addicted (shrieks).
- I might talk to them.
- It's been less than an hour
and I'm already starting to destroy it.
But it's stress relief.
- A man walking on the
road squishing a lemon,
that's kind of a weird look.
(truck horn)
However, I'm enjoying it.
- I've had them for a couple
days now and they still smell
frikkin delicious.
- Oh my gosh, smells like vanilla wafers.
- This smells like a marshmallow,
this smells like plastic.
- This smells good so.
- I like how long it takes to
go back to it's original form.
- [Girl] Squish, it looks sad.
- He's about to be happy in a second.
- I feel kind of wrong for
squishing this cute creature,
it's so cute, lemmi smash it.
- It's really kind of grown on me
and I still find myself subconsciously
squeezing it throughout the day
or like fiddling around with it.
I put it on my desk
just (knocking) mash it.
- I'm the type of person
that fidgets a lot
and I'm constantly biting on
my sweater and tapping my foot.
Little Dugong over here
has helped me a lot
with my fidgeting.
(speaks in foreign language)
- We're about to take off.
Usually this is when I
squeeze my husband's hand
because I do freak out
but these is gonna have to do this time.
- Squish Squish Squish.
- I did have a co-worker just
try to steal them from me,
not good.
- I feel so relaxed right now.
- [Woman] No I need it back, I like it.
I wanna go lay down with it.
- [Woman] No.
- When I saw everyone
in the office had them,
I wanted one really bad so I stole one.
- I forgot my daisy and
my feredigo right here
in this studio.
I didn't think it was
going to affect me so much.
Oh my God I miss them so
frieking much, I really did.
- I'm at the airport,
I had a minor freakout
because I thought I left it
at home and I went to grab it
and my heart stopped
cause I didn't think I
had it in my back pack.
I have become squishy reliant.
- I have an addiction.
- They're not really a
stress reliever for me,
they're more of my friends
and they keep me company.
I think some people are scared of me now.
- I've definitely noticed
that I've grown closer to it.
- I have to throw it away
cause I have destroyed
what I once loved.
So I literally squished it all weekend
while I was laying in bed sick.
I really love it and I'm
still holding and to it.
- These really brought out a side of me
that I did not expect to have.
- I was kinda surprised
that I was so emotionally
and physically attached to it.
- They are my best friend's now.
- I feel like it was a place
to channel anxiety subconsciously.
- It's been a really great stress reliever
for me I would say.
- Not a fan of flying.
If anything happens at least I'm gonna die
squeezing my squishies.
- It felt really therapeutic actually.
- I think its just having
something to do with my hands
while I'm focused on that activity.
- It looks like my dog chewed it
but it was just me.
Maybe I'm more stressed
out than I think that I am.
- I feel like maybe what I learned
is that toys aren't just for kids.
You play with toys and it can
take your mind off things.
- I also learn that I
love to squish things.
- It was a major surprise
to realize that yes,
they become apart of me, it's
almost like an extension.
- This is definitely staying on my desk.
- You can pry my squishy
outta my cold dead hands.
- [Woman] You can keep them.
- Yes!
There's no way you were
taking these from me anyways.
- I wish everybody could
feel how squishy this is.
Just like imagine.
(upbeat music)